Obst das war knapp in nur 44 tausend kilometern entfernung also nur etwas weiter entfernt als
stationären satelliten mit
36.000 kilometern flug der ab
2012 c c4 an der erde vorbei zum ersten mal wird jetzt aber ein solcher vorbeiflug genutzt
um vorbereitungen für den schutz der menschheit vor einschlägen solche asteroiden auf der erde vorzubereiten
Jetzt den klicks um science-fiction von der frankfurter buchmesse herzlich willkommen
Den atom
2012 c c4 kennen wir schon seit fünf jahren also 2012 wurde entdeckt aber in dieser zeit konnten wir ihnen nur sieben tage lang
beobachten das soll jetzt anders werden denn ein einschlag eines asteroiden wie
2012 den c4 hätte verheerend sein können ein anschlag direkt in einer großstadt hätte wirklich furchtbare folgen
Haben können bis zur vollständigen zerstörung wie bei einer atombombe der vorbeiflug soll jetzt genutzt werden um die asteroiden
erkennung und nachverfolgung
zu testen denn das ist die voraussetzung
Um in zukunft asteroiden aufzuspüren und dann zu zerstören oder eben ihre flugbahn zu ändern zum ersten, mal
Kommt dafür die neue behörde planetary die fans
koordination zum einsatz diese hatten usa letztes jahr eingerichtet
Um erdnahe asteroiden zu entdecken und zu verfolgen sie gelten als auslöser
Von massensterben auf der erde alle paar millionen jahre steuert ein großer asteroid auf die erde zu der das leben tatsächlich
Bedroht die nasa hat deswegen das ziel bis 2020 alle erdnahen asteroiden die größer als
140 meter sind zu entdecken denn genau diese könnten der erde gefährlich werden und zwar zu
einem millionen sterben für einen experten plädieren deshalb nun mal wieder für eine bessere weltweite zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines koordinierten
frühwarnsystems wirklich effektive abwehrstrategien sind aber noch nicht ausgezählt
2012 tcp wurde ja eben erst 2012 entdeckt damals konnte er aufgrund seines verlaufs
Allerdings nur wenige tage beobachtet werden seine größe ähnelt und welches thema szenen der im februar
2013 über russland explodiert war die explosion von chelyabinsk
hatte damals lediglich eine druckwelle ausgelöst sie beschädigte mehrere tausend gebäude und verletzte rund
100 menschen einen einschlag hätte dagegen die stadt komplett zerstört verglichen mit der hiroshima bombe
Hatte dieser asteroid die 20 bis 40 fache sprengkraft entsprechend tnt waren es 600 kilo das soeben sind ein
überbleibsel von der entstehung unseres sonnensystems die meisten von ihnen ziehen glücklicherweise weit entfernt von der erde
Um die sonne zwischen den planeten mars und jupiter und doch die erde ist ständig
bedroht von kollisionen mit erdgas
Zu jeden viele objekte sind klein und verglühen in der atmosphäre ohne dass wir es merken
Dass ein himmelskörper in die atmosphäre eintritt und explodiert oder einschlägt kommt allerdings öfter vor als wir denken
Wie oft das in den letzten 13 jahren passiert ist das wurde ja erst jüngst bekannt wir haben ja darüber berichtet
26 studenten sind auf der erde eingeschlagen bauch bekommen sind findige wissenschaftler sie hatten die idee beim weltweiten atomteststopp
Überwachungs netzwerk nachzufragen ob es andere größere explosionen auf der erde gab und es waren
26 in 13 jahren lediglich ein einschlag wurde dabei vorher gesehen alle anderen kamen
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes aus heiterem himmel
Jedes jahr schlagen also zwei größere asteroiden hier auf der erde ein und bisher
hatten wir großes glück denn die gesteinsbrocken schlugen mehr in wüsten oder in sonstigen unbewohnt und nein oder verdampften
Bereits in der atmosphären die jetzt begonnene bahn verteuerung ist also ein erster mega wichtiger schritt
Um die menschheit vor einer katastrophe zu schützen eine wahnsinnig wichtige
zivilisations leistung ohne die wir
Als menschheit auf dauer nicht überleben könnten wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
Mit athen bedrohen die erde jederzeit mit noch mehr infos zu den gefahren die von asse hinausgehen spannendes video klar
also nicht verpassen kauf klicken und ansonsten bislang
lag